welcome back and i just want to
apologize ahead of time because i'm
actually in a hotel right now because my
wife is at a medical conference and i'm
using my laptop with kind of ad hoc
configuration so it might not sound as
good as it normally does but let's just
try to to keep learning so let's start
off the way i start off every video but
maybe a little different this time so i
want to start a bank so i use 300 gold
pieces 100 to actually build a bank
100 to build a bank so this is more my
vault
the actual physical structure that took
100 gold pieces and then i'm actually
going to
initially capitalize this bank with 200
gold pieces
you actually want to show people what it
looks like for gold to be sitting in the
vault
so get the idea
so my initial equity is 300 gold pieces
300 gold pieces that's my equity or
whatever the investors were that
initially invested in this bank
and like all of the other examples i
start off by taking deposits the
villagers trust me so villager a
comes and gives me
let me just do villager and green he
comes and gives me his hundred gold
pieces
100
gold pieces this is all gold and then my
that's an asset sitting in my vault and
then the offsetting liability for me
although this would be an asset for him
is a checking account
so account
account for person a and he can write
checks against that and we know how that
can be used as actual currency or
actually be used to make payments
and then person b comes
he's a little bit richer
gives 200 gold pieces
200
gold pieces and he wants half of that in
his checking account and he wants the
other half essentially in cash
or in banknotes as we've learned so this
is
this is the account of b
account of villager b and then half of
it he wants in terms of bank notes so
this is this liability would be bank
notes outstanding
bank notes outstanding for 100 gold
pieces this is 100 right here this is a
hundred and i'll print up some bank
notes maybe he wants five
twenties
so i'll give them five times
and each of the bank notes might look
something like this
a twenty
gold piece denomination
have a picture of
the handsome bank founder and we'll say
bank of sal at the bottom
and i'll give it to him and then he
could use that for transactions with
people who maybe don't like to leave a
paper trail but anyway or or whatever
buying a newspaper whatever he needs to
do but he can use these and then whoever
he has these two if they have one of
these 20 gold piece bills they can come
back to the bank of cell and actually
redeem 20 gold pieces so it's kind of
like a checking account but you don't
know who actually has rights to it any
given moment in time but anyway we've
done that in the last couple of videos
and we've shown how you can change hands
and how when someone writes a check say
between a and b you're just kind of uh
you're just changing what happens in the
books and the goal never has to leave
but let's think about what happens now
when we actually start to lend some
money
so in the old example
if someone had a project that required
let's say
300 gold pieces we would actually give
them the 300 gold pieces we would
actually take it out of our vaults
they would use that 300 gold pieces to
hire the people or buy whatever supplies
they needed to actually
do their project and then those people
maybe would redeposit it back in the
bank and that process would continue
what we're going to do now is try to
think about how could we do this without
the bank with ever having to give the
gold out one it's just a safety concern
and then the gold is just not an easy
thing to transact with you don't if
someone you know wants to sell something
worth half a gold piece do they cut it
if someone wants to sell something with
a thousand gold pieces it's a security
risk and it weighs a lot so so what can
we do
so let's say entrepreneur
let's see we did a b and so let's do
entrepreneur c he has an idea let's see
it's the irrigation ditch again and he
needs 300 gold pieces so we do is we
lend him 300 gold pieces
so i have an asset
300
gold piece
loan
to entrepreneur
and instead of actually taking it out of
my assets here and then waiting for it
maybe for his laborers to redeposit it i
can just create a checking account for
entrepreneur c in fact it can be maybe
part checking maybe part cash what i
could do is maybe 100 of it i can make a
checking account
100 so it's an account for c that's a
checking account and then the other 200
i could put some more bank notes
outstanding
this is 200 bank notes outstanding
so maybe i do 20 maybe he wants it in
tens
20 times
and i give him a bunch of these things
that i printed out from the bank of cell
and maybe he could pay use this to pay
his laborers and if the laborers later
on they don't want to just hold these
pieces of paper they can come back to
the bank of sao and get gold in exchange
for it and then let's say another
entrepreneur comes and he wants to build
a factory he needs 100 gold pieces
i can do is
say he needs 100 gold pieces
so i have a loan
100
loan that's my asset
loan to entrepreneur d
and then i can create a checking account
for him
so
this is account
for
d and i know what you're thinking it
looks like i'm making money out of out
of nowhere i can just i'm just
increasing both the left and the right
hand side of the balance sheet for every
new loan i make and if you think about
this was actually not that different
when we act when we
issued the gold it's just that we had to
wait for the gold to come back to the
bank this is essentially a way of
keeping the gold here and we just use
these checking accounts and these bank
notes as a way of transacting instead of
the gold itself so for example let's say
this entrepreneur d he wants to build a
factory
let's say that person a is is the person
who actually builds the factory so what
let's see is f person d and have person
a
person d can write person a a check
you know he could write 100 you know
what a check looks like he'll sign it
person d he'll say it's for factory and
he'll write out 100 here and i'll write
it out in words however a check is just
something that shows it has to be
authenticated so that when a takes it
back to the bank the bank believes that
d actually wrote it in his checkbook as
opposed to somehow a forging it and in
return a is going to
build d a factory
a is going to build d a factory and then
when a takes this check that he got from
d brings it back to the bank then the
banks will say oh okay well d is going
to take all this money out of his
account we have to transfer it to a so i
could move that down or i could just
change it to a's color and i think you
get the point
all this hundred gold pieces is now a's
and once again we did not have to
change anything or we didn't have to
deal with any gold
now the natural question is how far can
this process continue can a bank just
continue issuing loans and checking
accounts indefinitely and and
essentially
collecting the difference in the
interest between the interest it gets on
the loan and the interest it gives on
the checking account well no because
then a bank would take on arbitrary
amounts of risk and there are
regulations although i think a bank
would do it on their own to some degree
but there are regulations called reserve
requirements that tell us how much
how much lending can a bank do
relative to
its actual reserves uh in this case its
reserves of gold
actually even a better definition how
much how much checking accounts and bank
notes it can issue relative to its
reserves in the next video the point of
this video was showing you how this loan
process can occur with the gold never
leaving and the next video will actually
talk about reserve requirements and
think about why reserve requirements are
what they are and what happens uh if in
extreme circumstances see in the next
video